hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round five of this year's
katar Masters it is Vali versus Shams
invid of of usbekistan and um uh you
guys requested this game for several
reasons one it's a it's a very nice game
it's played to almost pretty much
Perfection and another thing uh this
tournament is 160 players and Vali here
uh is currently number 13 ahead of
Magnus Carlson who is in 14th Place and
GES who is in 15 uh and bear in mind
she's she still hasn't gotten her her
Grandmaster title she is still an
international master and she's U well
playing some incredible chess uh so
let's check it out here she has the
white pieces and we have a very very
cool line of the uh con Sicilian E4 we
have Pawn to C5 Knight to F3 Pawn to E6
and D4 captures captures and now not
going for Knight to F6 and then A6 like
you see in the nidorf uh here we have
Pawn to A6 right away this is the
variation and um there are not okay
there are a lot of games um with the con
of course not nearly as much as of the
nro but after she played Pawn to H3
there are maybe three games in the
database with this um exact same setup
so this is uh already can be considered
a completely new position uh but I will
not call it just yet Knight to C6 Knight
captures B captures and Bishop to D3 and
here there is a game where Queen to C7
was played it was actually played this
year song Edward
against luuka budavich in Washington and
um the game was won by song Edward but
here we have Knight to F6 and it is now
as of move seven that we have a
completely new game now we usually say
if you're allowed to play D5 in the ceil
you should just play it and you're going
to be okay but here uh it's not so clear
for example D5 castles what do you play
you don't want to capture and UND double
uh and mess up your Pawn structure then
you have you're going to have an
isolated a and isolated C pawn and uh
you can just capture with a bishop and
if a queen trade happens you can capture
with the rook and if Knight to F6 uh
let's say Knight to D2 and G6 now you
want to uh for example fto there's B3
very annoying and now if Bishop G7
Bishop A3 just stops castling and you're
going to have to resort to some Bishop
to f8 moves and it's not maybe uh the
best so while D5 will be played and
should be played maybe not right away so
first we have Knight to F6 going after
the pawn here uh castles and now Pawn to
D5 so playing it um after after
developing a piece we have Knight to D2
and now not going for G6 because of B3
we already said that this will be quite
annoying for black Bishop to E7 we have
Pawn to B3 castles and now Bishop to B2
we have Pawn to A5 trying to mess up the
pawn structure on the queen side with
Pawn to A4 and Vali stops it by playing
Pawn to A4 herself and well okay C5
Maybe does look like a a move you want
to play but it's not all that
spectacular for example Queen to E2 and
after Queen to C7 Rook a to D1 and now
if you if you want you can close the
position with D4 but then you allow
Knight to C4 then maybe in the future E5
Knight to D6 and so on maybe giving
white a little bit too much so instead
Knight to D7 uh this is a a great plan
because if you look at the position now
why has two uh incredible Bishops here I
would call them monster Bishops just yet
but once the light Square Bishop opens
up it's definitely going to be a bishop
pair from Hell while the Bishop on E7
and Bishop on C8 aren't doing all that
much so by playing Knight to D7 you want
to trade off your dark Square Bishop for
the dark Square Bishop on B2 and also
your light Square Bishop for the light
Square Bishop on D3 so this will be the
next step of shop Cid's plan uh we have
Rook to E1 and now Bishop to F6 uh we
have Bishop captures and and not not
much you can do about this trade Queen
captures and now Knight to F3 with
Bishop to A6 trading off the other
Bishop as well and now e captures on D5
first C captures and Bishop captures on
A6 we Rook captures on A6 and now Pawn
to C4 so uh okay shamin did get to trade
off the the two Bishops but now he
allowed Pawn to C4 which cannot be taken
as the Knight on D7 would hang and uh uh
you you could play something uh maybe
something like well it it's very hard to
say in the game uh Rook to D6 was played
um but the the pawn still will not be
able to capture on C4 as The Rook on D6
is also uh hanging it's not a blunder or
anything you it can be played it's just
very difficult um to actually play it
and here we have Queen to
D2 um going after the A5 pawn and now
the way you want to play this is play
Rook to A8 you just defend the pawn and
now after Rook eight to D1 you bring the
queen back Queen to d8 while your Rook
is nicely developed and defending the A5
Pawn however that did not happen in the
game after Queen to D2 shamid didn't
tried a different approach he played
Knight to C5 he said all right we trade
the A5 Pawn for the B3 pawn and then I
capture on C4 as well however this is a
bit problematic for black queen captures
on A5 we have Knight captures on B3 and
now Queen to B4 attacking the Knight and
the rook and now Knight captures on A1
grabbing The Rook here Queen captures on
D6 and now Knight to C2 attacking The
Rook on E1 and now it seems like uh he
solved all of his problems but there is
one huge problem for him the game is
completely winning for Vali uh feel free
to pause the video and try to figure it
out while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on figuring out that
black is completely busted and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Rook to B1 and now the problem is
you cannot capture on C4 just to give
you an example if D captures on C4 Rook
to B8 and that's it there's no defense
Rook captur some B8 or queen captur some
B8 is coming if you trade then just
Queen captures Queen to d8 and queen
captures on d8 Checkmate so uh uh this
is a huge problem for black so of course
uh you have
to uh you know add more support to the
back rank so Queen to d8 was played
offering a queen trade and keeping an
eye on that B8 square but now Pawn to C5
this does give black a pass Pawn but
also the White Pass Pawn is now um well
Unstoppable we have Knight to A3
attacking The Rook now Rook to B7 with
we have Knight to C4 going after the
queen and just Queen captures on d8 Rook
captures and pawn to C6 the pawn is now
Unstoppable if you of course try Rook C8
then just C7 followed by Rook to B8 that
will not work so in the game King to f8
was played and now Pawn to C7 Rook to C8
and Rook to B8 going after the Rook so
now you block Knight to D6 uh and now
Knight to D4 this is key if you try A5
which seems like it should be winning
also a king E7 unpins the rook and now
Rook captures on C7 is possible and if
you trade here Rook captures Knight
captures A6 the Knight actually covers
both A7 and C8 Square so you will not be
queening either of your pawns so after
Knight D6 Knight to D4 the only winning
move by shy plays it and now uh there's
really not much to play for King D7 was
played now Knight to B5 attacking the
defender of The Rook on C8 and even if
you try something like Knight captures
on B5 which seems like uh maybe you
maybe it could work after Rook captures
on C8 and King to D7 Rook to f8 that's
the problem yes you do win the C7 Pawn
but then Rook starts gobbling up the
king side pawns King to C6 you're going
to capture here and yes you can push the
D4 Pawn but Rook captures on A7 and if
D3 King F1 easily stops the pawn so not
much to play for here so after Knight to
B5 we have Pawn to D4 and now King to F1
uh the king now joins uh the attack you
don't have to play it right away but you
know you don't uh
uh waste time or anything it's it's a
useful move that will have to be played
so Pawn to F6 and now Pawn to A5 uh
there's really not all that much you can
try here uh King to D7 was played and
now Knight captures on D6 finally
removing that Defender Of The Rook here
Rook captures on C7 uh if you go for the
Knight of course The Rook just hangs so
you can play that King captures and C7
also just Rook captures and C8 um uh
impossible so Rook captures on C7 was
played but now Knight to B5 and he was
in this position un move 35 that sham
inoko resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here uh so he
he's down a piece and okay you can maybe
throw in a few more moves like Rook C1
King E2 and Rook to A1 going after the
pawn but after Rook to A8 there is zero
counterplay here even with some fancy
moves like Pawn to E5 you you will play
Pawn to A6 and if Rook to A5 going after
the Knight because you can Advance the
pawns as long as the Knight is here this
is covered by the king if you push this
the Knight captures on D4 and if you
attack the Knight you can even sacrifice
the Knight because after Rook captures
you can just move the rook and promote
the pawn to a queen next there's really
not uh all that much you can do here
Rook captures Rook captures and now the
EAS the uh Rook easily defeats a long
King uh so very nicely done by Vali and
um like I said uh she is currently in
number 13 ahead of Magnus Carlson and
gesh and her opponent for the next round
will be gesh himself so we'll see how
she takes on a former member of the of
the top 10 in World classical I believe
gkes is now number 13 in In classical
chess but still 2758 that is one one um
strong opponent so we'll see how IAL
does so far she's undefeated three wins
and two draws uh uh you know very few
people in the tournament can actually
say that
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh very weird variation
especially since after the the con
variation was met with this H3 very
weird stuff but this just means that
they avoided all Theory and they had to
start playing chess pretty much from
from move one uh so that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it I would like to wish
a very happy birthday to aushi and I
would like to thank nagarjuna ponugoti
David William grasberger uh Avery fto
and Tucker Berkman for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your
day